arielle dombasle est ce que vous avez
entendu parler des questions cons non
et
imaginons par exemple courant contre un
type génial rêve de votre vie
celui avec qui vous avez vraiment envie
de vous marier il est beau il est riche
il est intelligent il a toutes les
qualités et il vous dit moi je viens de
mariée avec vous avec toi tu que cette
prime en live de tutoiera mais à une
condition c'est une variété votre
carrière de chanteuse de réalisatrice
d'actrice ou alors deuxième solution
vous ne rencontrez jamais cet homme là
et vous terminez votre carrière
grandement comme tout le monde peut
consulter la terminer nuit est ce que
vous choisissez la conscience de soi
c'est la première solution 1 sur farfus
sur le thème de l'amour ah bon donc les
postulants peuvent pas se présenter
absolument deuxième question qu'on vous
devez partir sur l'île déserte avec un
garçon oui est-ce que vous préféré
partir avec un blanc un jaune un noir ou
un rouge je ne partirai pas sur une île
déserte
parce que je pense que ce n'est pas
intéressant ce n'est pas leur est
théoriquement fait pour être le rêve le
désert je ne crois pas je crois par
c'est quoi pour vous la meilleure île
déserte du monde alors je partirai pour
un voyage interplanétaire
bon alors avec l'hymne national gallery
j'emmènerai tous dans le vaisseau tous
tous en bonne réponse alors là on va
passer une question un peu plus un peu
plus sérieuse est ce que vous seriez
prête à donner votre vie car vous avez
vous mourriez instantanément si grâce à
ça on trouver un vaccin un remède contre
le sida
attention à ce que vous allez dire oui
écoutez moi je veux bien mourir mais par
amour
alors si ça devait guérir mon fiancé du
sida ni bonnes réponses
voilà si vous deviez être incarné vous
croyez l'incarnation
je n'y crois pas mais j'aime y croire
bon est-ce que vous préfériez est
réincarné en chien berger allemand
c'était un rendez vous et pagnol breton
à la dure oui si un berger allemand
pourquoi parce que comme ça j'aurai m tu
pourras nous dresser